yes sir it's your boy young nudity man
check me out on the bootleg here boy I
can't down but I can't podcast
so you got that go go do that
bootleg Camp podcast bootleg Capt show
special guest in here
got one of my favorite songs out right
now going crazy all over the radio
young nudie is here
what's up man
this is how we're just getting high
today
oh I see it's a it's a it's a bad uh
burn on that
it's all good
which one did you line up the toe jam
let me get the lighter I'll smoke with
you
you might as well both be high right
yeah why not
so uh
congrats on everything man I feel like
is this record like your biggest song
ever at Radio
but I'm saying like you obviously have
got a crazy catalog you've been
murdering it I mean I wouldn't say
necessarily on the Underground scene but
you've been murdering it for a very long
time for the better part of the last
like six years or so is it like cool now
to like be able to like get in the car
and turn on the turn on the radio and
like you're playing it's like a little
different it hits different
yeah somebody let me know you know I'll
just tell them no no no
I don't listen to radio I mean nobody I
mean I won't say nobody does because I'm
on the radio in like 30 markets so
but nobody listens to the radio that's
like you know have like has like you
like you're listening to Spotify or
apple music which one do you want bro
just say but you know what don't answer
that we don't want to piss off the dsps
you're on all of them
so you still haven't actually heard your
song being played like live on the radio
like you get in the car and sound like
the [__] Uber or something like that
oh
you don't write it not even the Uber
black the Uber XL oh yeah I'm rolling
that [__] but I don't just like everyday
riding all over
I feel you and I when I get an Uber I
like to ask for the auction you get the
auction yeah yeah play your own [__]
yeah yeah nobody else is [__] getting
playing in the Hawks yeah a lot of
people should get played on uh who are
you a fan of that's like because I feel
like you know
you're obviously uh
based on the the music that you've put
out your your musical taste is a high
level who are you feeling right now
that's on the come up
oh
what a cool baby dread all the time
shout it hard you know my baby Drew
you gotta get in tune baby drill I've
been listening a lot of Detroit [__]
lately yeah how far with Detroit [__]
too but you gotta get into baby drill
hard from Atlanta yeah from Atlanta okay
yeah oh baby drill
um
H dog
uh
I like moneybag yo um little artist
though
is that the dude um if I think the FTB
fat or some [__] like that yep yep yep
shout it hard he's fired yeah I like it
have you heard of this dude in uh
Dallas named big X the plug no I don't
know he's fire
check him out yeah he's hard all right
he's like my favorite new artist yeah
this big giant dude from Dallas Texas
[__] rap though and then I
loved it I love all the Detroit what his
name is again big X the plug big hits
the plug just a big ass dude who could
spit for sure I say that feels about
big it's the plug okay he's hard
um man well first of all congrats on the
album Gumbo's out now yeah might be the
dopest artwork of the year for an album
you're always very like high level on
your album art
there's always a theme there's
everything's always kind of connected
for you like
is that like starting your brain are you
high and you're like I got an idea for
this album art and then you give it to
your graphic designer because your
artwork's always crazy
like
until like kind of like what I kind of
want type [__] and then [__] they kind
of really just go from now my last two
artwork
um
yeah Elijah the dude named Elijah he did
the [__] killer yeah
for sure white gumbo
cook out now a little something for
everybody yeah and plus you know I got a
lot of food food names songs and [__] so
I just came up with like
let me check on the gym make one little
[__] with your number food and I ain't
so now all right hey that makes sense
yeah I respect it
uh would you would you judge me harshly
if I told you I've never eaten gumbo in
my life
oh I won't judge I've never had gumbo
you're right
oh boy you know I went to New Orleans
and I think it was either a po boy or
gumbo and I said give me the po boy yeah
yeah
I feel like that's like a Down South
thing though I'm from I'm from Arizona
yeah what y'all got out there
tacos Taco yeah oh [__] I never wrong
with that love tacos
is there even good Mexican food in
Atlanta
um [__]
[Music]
I can't really see because that means
that there's not any good mix if I go I
I really
I ain't gonna sit here and say like I
don't eat Mexican food in other states
if I eat in some other states and then I
go back to Georgia then I'll be able to
but as for right now I really don't know
enjoys like I don't play well so you're
not a big Mexican food connoisseur no
yeah no oh I got it let me change your
life a little it's the best food in the
world
spicy food no no it doesn't have to be
spicy you got to get Pastor it's like
when you go to the taco truck what is
Pastor what is that it's like pork do
you like do you like the swine oh you
don't eat the swine do you eat steak
Yeah I use steak okay so you could have
carne asada then yeah you get a side of
tacos now if you ever made an exception
to eat the swine you should try Pastor
it's [__] it'll change your life no I
I ain't gonna eat this one I don't know
anyway this one would you eat goat
it's a taco
and it comes with like a almost like a
cup of sauce
you dip your taco in yeah it's [__]
gas bro man I gotta man we got listen
you got a show coming up in L.A and is
it June 29th yeah at the novo
we're in May right now
sometime in the next 30 days we gotta go
get some [__] tacos
have you ever had El Salvadorian food
like a Pupusa
is like a Salvadorian version of a taco
but it's [__] fire yeah
well I'm sure he's got that [__] turned
up yeah
we got to get you uh man some of this so
I love Atlanta because
um Atlanta is uh obviously top tier
strip club
Cuisine yeah
uh blue flame I I feel like was the best
wings I had out there blue fly
yeah I went to Magic City I was a little
disappointed in the wings yeah they were
tiny oh
which place has the best wings in your
opinion it could be either of those
places or a third option
uh um I'm gonna say I'm Jay Gonna Keep
It on the script club tip for right now
okay how many strip clubs what I mean
yeah me my favorite play that probably
got the big wing I mean this [__] ain't
built in the club but it's outside part
of it right now to the club it's a
little wing spot in that the stroke
what's it after stroller next to stroke
oh Strokers okay yeah man that [__] yeah
hits but you got to be in the parking
lot to get it yeah you just got to go
outside the club but now the people in
the club the way they'll go get this
you're gonna get it for you yeah yeah
okay right now throw it like they plug
in what are you trying to touch it
the strip club there
um
where they had the lamb chops but it's
like kind of like they play White music
right now so you'll go there and get the
Lamb Chop yeah yeah it's a good spot let
me know when you come right now so when
you're at cheetahs
and they play like Nickelback
for like Aerosmith they'd be up they're
dancing like damn bro see they don't
even dance they just do that like slow
like
yeah I mean the little Grand Theft Auto
you can't you can't dance the Nickelback
you know what I'm saying like you could
but like
you know it's kind of hard to do have
you ever been to the Claremont Lounge
where the hell is Nickelback
it's in Atlanta it's a strip club with
elderly women and midgets what the [__]
[Music]
yeah
hey oh hell no a guy named Jared Benton
took me there and uh where how long was
it a bunch of old folks and midgets yeah
it's like a freak Show it's like you go
up in there and you get a dance from
like a 79 year old abroad for sure
fun time though it's like you know not
I'm not into that you know but it's like
it's like how long you stayed in though
30 minutes 30 minutes I was in and out I
just had to see it how many grandmas you
have zero
I just I just I I looked
and there was literal midgets in there
are you ready and I don't know if that's
okay to say anymore
there were people shorter than four feet
in there
[__] Mitch's got a [__] too though they
do but I'm not sure you're supposed to
say midgets well short people little the
little people got little people yeah man
the little people you've ever been with
a little person no
have you ever thought to yourself I give
it a shot
I thought myself one time for a lot that
was a fine ass little shout Mitch I
probably
right
[Laughter]
do you remember the porn star Pinky do
you remember pinky Back in the Day pinky
she was like the black shirt yeah
she's super super by the way shout out
to her you know
we don't want a fat chamber but yeah she
looks like you know her last night could
probably share clothes right shout out
to lizzo
um with that being said uh she's kind of
like a [__]
yeah yeah I saw her at the Porn
Convention one year
I lived in Vegas at the time it's not
like I was like flying and getting Rooms
To Go to a Porn Convention I lived in
Vegas I got free tickets I went all
right she's [__] tiny bro
damn and just watch she's like a [__]
like a thumb you know what I'm saying
that [__] here like a thong bam where
shout out to
um pinky Pinky's a legend yeah she's
definitely a pinky
you ever uh frequent any of those 24 7
Spas they have in Atlanta
you know so crazy I ain't never been to
no Spa
they got like that block over there and
it's just hella spas
you know what I'm talking about the
street the strip clubs and spots oh it's
crazy I heard about that whatever I
haven't been inside but my friend says
it's very uh very uh you know it's like
the type of spot you go to and they yeah
they rub you and they tug you oh oh no
no hell no you sound like a little full
pedestrian or some [__] like that
oh man how you feeling uh are you a big
basketball fan
so you're not like really tapped in with
what's going on like those the Lakers
lost and I mean you know I'd be saying
little highlights and [__] I might see
on Instagram or some [__] some
oh no hell no I like I like watching
highlights of some [__] here yeah
highlights are great because you don't
have to sit through anything I ain't
watching this [__] what do you you know
what happened with John Moran obviously
right
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I feel like
he wants to be a rapper
do you have any advice for him for when
his rap career starts
John Moran mixtape gonna be crazy
I don't know so I can't really you know
no I can't really speak on nobody else
[__] like if you okay let's say not John
Moran just anybody else but he need to
get there and protect that money on
though he does need to protect that
money that's all I can really say and
get off Instagram live yeah all right
that's me do you go on IG live a lot no
I'm different
yeah your IG is very inconspicuous
it's very uh I feel like you always keep
it very minimal yeah all right the word
don't even know too much you don't do a
ton of interviews you've obviously done
like done over the years but you're like
you don't do a lot is that on purpose
you know oh
I just get some poem I feel like a
[__] be asking me sign of course
right like would you [__] [__] yeah
no hell no they ain't asking me no [__]
like that
so I'm I got first first time first time
doing that
is it I don't know how do you feel like
sometimes be asking me the same [__] you
feel
um
and I really just don't like doing too
many interviews and [__]
um
what is your uh
your favorite song on Gumbo
or it is a change
I don't really like I don't really like
picking right between like picking it's
like picking from your kids yeah so but
I don't know
when I wake up and type [__] yeah are
you excited uh for the tour
the tour yeah
all right let me tell you that I was
like oh the hell they [__] no because no
because because you've have you done the
novel opening up before no I don't know
I've seen you in L.A opening for
somebody maybe like three or four years
ago
um
who are you on tour with maybe it was
two years ago
somebody probably my goodness or some
[__] yeah maybe
I saw you open it for somebody
um but for you you know a lot of people
like they have that moment in La they do
the Roxy and then they end up doing the
novo and then the next go around usually
is like
[__] Microsoft theaters crypto Arena
or some [__]
it's a pretty big deal to be able to
sell out the novo dolo
you feel like La is like a big market
for you like are you tapped in what's
going on here on the music scene like I
don't really be knowing no no no we're
talking about uh I'm becoming guys do
you listen any of the new guys in La at
all or anybody on your radar no I ain't
gonna lie to you soon that's how I do
yeah that's one wonderful thing yeah you
gotta tap in with a have you ever
listened to Grio
03 Greedo
yeah yeah I never heard so I'm just
gonna he was in prison uh for like three
or four years yeah yeah he just got out
fire gotta tap in
for you
um in 2023 man
you got an album out tours over show on
the 29th at the novo
any more music coming this year
I don't know
are you the type of artist that has like
hard drives and hard drives that
unreleased [__] oh yeah I got a lot of
[__] [__] I I could drop some [__] man I
can do all type of [__] man I could drop
[__] with producers y'all probably
wouldn't even think I got a whole bunch
of [__] with no type of [__] yo did you
ever find out a couple years ago when
your [__] got uh leaked online did you
ever find out who there was like a
hacker that leaked all your [__] or a
lot of your [__] did you ever find out
who did it uh
God said it wasn't meant to be yeah is
that usually is that because I always
hear when my [__] [__] gets leaked
it's usually an engineer or something
gets left on like a hard drive that's at
a recording studio or something like was
that what happened there did someone
just like
pull some inspector gadgets [__] I think
it was some respect the gadget [__]
because I don't know I don't do no [__]
like that but I don't know [__] I mean
yeah it did what it is now [__] that
[__] wow who's on your Mount Rushmore of
Atlanta Hip Hop all time
[__] I don't know
um [__] [__] right now who yours
let me see I'm gonna go Andre 3 000.
that's a good one
tip
easy
future
no I gotta take TI off Jeezy
future Gucci
okay and Andre 3 000. 13
000 good too I like that lineup right
now I like that that's a good lineup
what's your lineup man I don't really
got one give me give me four
[__] I ain't got one you ain't got you
give me some names that should be
considered rappers who's sitting in the
waiting room waiting to hear their name
called to be on the Mount Rushmore
[Laughter]
oh no let me see it George
um I'm gonna say future
I'm gonna say Gucci we like that old
Gucci locked in on that [__]
best a r and Hip Hop yeah except little
whop that was awesome
[Music]
oh [__] nudity
that's a good great answer seven Great
enhancer oh
oh baby drill
you know who I would put on there too oh
well who I should put on there if I
could put them all on as one the Migos
the Amigo yeah I might take off
Gucci
for the Migos as a whole yeah yeah
they like the whole Migos as a group all
three
as one person I just listen to the Migos
a lot the oh they oh man so good yeah
yeah oh [__] too that was a that was a
funny yeah that was an ERA Peewee too
yeah PeeWee Longway yeah and we don't
get enough uh give him more credit man
he's supposed to get a lot more crack he
was hard Scooter's hard too we be on
that boot in the night light huh be on
that boot and not like
say what
to be on the boot at night
it back in the day [__]
we should be on the boot in Nightline
we went over there please explain okay
so boo they're the molly
oh okay so yeah at least be on my mind
so the Molly's be running around the
lobby forever
you just be running around on Molly
well a little man back in no day let me
see back in the book day the bank or we
probably used list two probably goddamn
future
bloody J
PeeWee Longway
amigo
never really they're really bad
never really about it for real for real
airplanes some other [__] that was
from Atlanta but
um they probably was a plus size [__]
so we're gonna fall down we're gonna
keep it going oh yeah yeah yo what up
it's bootleg cab we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our folks at
my bookie that's right so many ways you
can gamble with my bookie right now man
of course you got NBA playoffs Western
Conference Finals Eastern Conference
Finals they're set I love Celtics vs
Lakers in the finals all right you can
sign up at mybookie.ag right now using
that promo code bootleg and get a very
generous first deposit bonus that's
right and they just got the craziest
like revamp of the online casino it's
like a Las Vegas experience if you play
cards Blackjack roulette uh you shoot
dice whatever it is they have like live
dealers handling it for you wherever
you're at you could be at the airport
and be playing [__] roulette on your
phone it's amazing mybookie.ag sign up
with that promo code bootleg right now
you can bet on Sports you can do slots
you could do Blackjack uh craps whatever
you're into mybookie.a g promo code
bootleg for that first deposit bonus and
it is a generous one also gotta give a
shout out to our family at King Palms
shout out to King Palm man if y'all know
about King Palms they're our new sponsor
on the bootleg kept podcast and they got
such a great product the best thing
about King Palms is it's all organic man
no tobacco in these wraps they're
straight Leafs and the best thing uh
about them is they got this product
their flavor terpene tips all right you
stuff them with your with your product
do we got one here oh we do got one here
we got one right here we got one right
here all right you stuff this with your
uh premium cannabis from Hardy in Las
Vegas
all right you smoke up pinch that tip
you're gonna get a burst of flavor yeah
this is the energy drink flavor we got
Peach pineapple we got watermelon wave
also don't forget the goddamn
blue grapes you know what I mean and
also this is a tobacco-free wrap it's
totally organic it's literally a leaf
let me show you what I mean
that is just a big ass Leaf guys all
right so what you could do is go to
kingpom.com weeds flying everywhere
kingpop.com promo code bootleg and uh
you can get 50 off of whatever you order
at kingpom.com and don't forget to check
them out because they're everywhere your
local smoke shop your local liquor store
7-Eleven smoke the King Palm all right
it's organic it ain't like all that
other [__] y'all be [__] stuffing
in your lungs man all right shout out to
kingpong kingpom.com promo code bootleg
right now and it's actually promo code
bootleg Kev
half off everything let's get back to
the interview what's it like uh to to
because I've never done Molly yeah I've
only done shrooms and I've only I smoke
weed and I drink
no Molly ever in my life yeah
there's Molly on like sex with Molly's
indeed better
where from strong no no just like from
being sober like having sex on a Molly
Isn't all it's you know kind of cut up
to be because you always
[__] no one else back in the day back in
the day you wouldn't [__] on tomorrow
yeah yeah how was it [__] it was very it
was
[Music]
have you ever done a honey pack I had a
pet yeah
from the gas station
no they work great they do this is also
a great opportunity y'all make sure you
go to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg and sign up
for a month a free blue true which is
the same active ingredient as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable form delivered to
your door
yeah
shout out to Bluetooth they're dick
pills they're our sponsor oh what the
[__] it's a [__] y'all getting
sponsored by the dick of course
um it's a good bag and it's a very very
I don't know you know I don't know
nobody needs I drink a lot of water
you've never been so [__] up after the
club that you just know like damn I'm
drunk like there's head don't get you
hard yeah but you be drunk you can't go
all the way like you might be able to
get a blow okay
[__]
did you say that wet mouth yeah oh God
that way
you've had a girl who doesn't have a wet
nose
oh no she looks like she's a cottonmouth
look here now look here now I'm just
asking uh anyway
shout out to uh to the wet Mouse out
there yeah man shout out to the wet
Mouse out though are you in a
relationship
single
undisclosed
my whole life as I disclosed you do a
good job of being undisclosed yeah
who would you consider your uh your
biggest influences that kind of like
where your motivation to like get into
music and start like really you know
taking it serious
oh [__]
oh no like like
really late
that just motivated me to like take it
seriously yeah like to like be like okay
it's time to [__] you know
take this I go 10 toes in on the rap
[__] because I feel like a lot of people
they they do like 50 50 and that's when
they end up [__] up you know I ain't
go which I ain't gonna say like I just
idolized some rap or some [__] just like
like
Gucci and all them type of rappers and
G's and all them type of rap they've
been uh but they wouldn't like oh made
me like oh yeah yeah I want a rap right
you see what I'm saying like hell no it
wasn't no [__] lined up right
I don't know what the hell it was for
real for real
what really motivated me to just feel
like a [__] like me could do it with
seeing my cousin do this [__] you feel
me yeah I mean and he the one who
motivate me to tell me like bro you need
to got now
[__] with the rap [__] go all the way in
with it yeah yeah yeah for real for real
um you've had some pretty crazy shows
obviously uh you've done wrong how many
times you've done rolling Cloud now
I feel like now with rolling loud
there's like a rolling loud in every
major city in the world so it's like
yeah it's crazy I just how they did the
Philippines but what's been your wildest
Moment On Stage man where you were like
this [__] is you looked out you saw the
[__] people and you just like kind of
couldn't believe you were playing for
that many people oh [__] my first show
my first show
that was my first show that you ever
shot me
yeah
ever since then I ain't never really had
no shoulders just shot me
I don't really get over excited about
[__] and [__] like that and [__] you
feel me I just
you know
have you ever been somewhere where you
were surprised that you had fans
because you know this Rapture is
worldwide man like you might be in like
[__] New Zealand or some [__] I mean
there's definitely fanciers in New
Zealand but like
um
I mean I ain't never been overseas but
that probably like one of the main
places where I'd be surprised like wow
You'll see people like hit you up or tag
you on my Instagram and [__] folk got
now my boy I don't need to speak what
the [__] they talking about you know
what I'm saying so but you haven't been
overseas yet no yeah no
you guys you got your passport yeah I
got it you gotta go man go on vacation
I'll just be dealing with a lot of [__]
type [__] have you been to Mexico yet
you haven't been a Cancun or like uh I
ain't never been to Mexico really Canada
hell no
I'll be him they do they don't let you
come back and [__] yeah it depends on
what you're I don't know what you're I
mean not I don't know yeah I ain't going
over there
or the weekend
the weekend what is uh what are you
watching on TV right now young nudie are
you are you watching any shows what's
the last thing you binge watched the
last show up I'm watching on TV like the
last show out there watching on TV what
you watching uh the last song watching
on TV
um Superman
super wet Superman Superman yeah
that's a show like a series
oh that's the uh it's on like the WB or
CW yeah it's a [__] lineup yeah I'm kind
of relate to it but other than that you
know I watch all the anime I'm on all
them [__] so I don't need yo my kids
love anime my son's about to be 18 and
he's like [__] yeah all kinds of
swords and costumes and [__] and I'm
wrong with that he gonna live forever
what is uh
in your opinion the best anime ever
damn well that kind of hard
by the way you want some more weed next
little number two you know if you want
another one
uh I don't know how high you're trying
to get
oh oh this is my last [__] of the day so
I'm going in this the last video today
well not really how many blocks we don't
smoke though to be the last one this is
that's your first one on your land
your second what time are you
it's 3 15.
315 yeah
I wouldn't what they like my what what
they like my what
I feel sick
probably by myself sixth yeah
will you smoke a joint instead of eating
a meal sometimes
I gotta smoke before I eat
so you won't replace like a meal with a
[__] joint like instead of eating on
the smoke because some people do that
with cigarettes
they'll have a cigarette instead of
eating yeah they like smoke cigarette
before they eat this [__] nah they'll
have a cigarette because it kind of
suppresses their appetite so people who
are like fat well they probably
shouldn't be smoking
but if you're like um you're like you
know like if pinky wanted to live hey
man we love fat people
just to let y'all know that man my mom's
a fat white lady shout out to her yeah
my mama fat hey man hey the good ones
are big baby the good ones are shout out
to your mom
um now you can have a cigarette and it
will replace a meal yeah yeah
that's not a terrible idea
what about video games do you game yeah
what are you into all right nah just be
on PC oh so you're serious I feel like
if someone tells me they got a PC that
means that they they got a whole their
series
I like GTA you be on like any servers on
there doing the cosplay
right now to serve that I'd be in a lot
the most I've been [__] called true
story true story in that server do you
have to be on the mic doing role playing
yeah type [__] I don't really be
streaming this [__] I don't do that [__]
do they know it's you there's a few
people now knowing me but I really
bought like my homeboys like what's your
username now what am I using no don't
say it but it's not like young nudie
1000 is it um you know so crying ain't
got no pitch on my [__] so a lot of
people probably see it don't even think
of me the thing with my [__] is y'all
know before we had some [__] like that
oh so now people can play oh that my
dick or [__] you got a Discord yeah oh
you're [__] into it Bud yeah I still
got nowhere I go I might not be
screaming but I know what's going on
you're in yo you you've never done um
twitch where you play games and your
fans can watch yes I did that's it you
know like there's people getting really
rich off of that I know like T Grizzly
is [__]
might as well change this occupation
they just put out a great mixtape with
Skillet baby but he's making like 100
Grand a month shout out again at my um
T-Pain makes like two that makes it hard
so T-pain have you seen T-Pain he'd be
on Twitch playing all kind of wild [__]
you should get on that twitch bro but
you know you also might get canceled
because you're live
like I couldn't do twitch because I'd be
[__] up and I'd say some wild [__] you
know what I'm saying that one
you over expose yourself yeah maybe in
like 10 years you know that'd be a trip
yeah like that's the one thing is like
you go on live it's live you can't ain't
no edits you can't hear me yeah yeah so
GTA what is your uh like if you let's
say you break character on the mic is
there repercussions for that
because you're doing the role playing so
you like talking like yo what's up give
me your [__] money bro
okay bro we gotta go bust this Mission
at the jewelry store
I don't know about that [__] like that
yeah you know because I was T Grizzly
told me that in his server if you break
character that kill you
oh damn they're like smoke you in the
game and then if you break character I
think like more than three times you get
kicked off the server for life oh I want
some [__] like that oh breaking
character like let [__] know
who you with like oh you talking about I
don't care to type [__] no you can't be
like hey bro what the [__] man I'm
[__] taking a getting a drink no if
you're on a mission you gotta be like oh
[__] yeah let's let's get to the [__]
Ops bro oh yeah what you mean like that
RPA this [__] all the way yeah type [__]
yeah oh [__] I guess so [__] IP and [__]
what you know I come you know
I like them RP sir where you can jail
with the [__] down there like real like
you coming that regular kick right
that's all I do have you done the uh the
Oculus delicious with the little thing I
ain't did that [__] it's pretty crazy
um
it's like they need to make some [__]
where you can like feel and [__] they do
yeah they got it there they go
they already got like you know like you
get the gloves they got [__]
making porns for the gloves damn yeah
it's crazy oh boy I know everybody gonna
have that [__] the thing about
the the uh the headset with the porn is
cool and [__] but like
a lot a lot of selection right now yeah
like I had blue face put on the thing
and he he told me to put on a porno
pulse hanging with blue face watching
porno on a [__] on Oculus
[Music]
but he looked down and he was like bro
my dick is pink so look don't check this
out about that fair enough look look
check this out
you have been to the middle version yeah
I walked around a little I have Oculus
like take stuff yeah like you crappy
saying they'd be like like it'd be real
money [__] going on in the [__]
can you can you take [__] in that Mama I
could you rob someone yeah
I'm sure you could
people be robbing that's it of course
taking people real money I mean it's
have you heard a [__] cryptocurrency
this [__] guy I'll be saying like the
virtual [__] people walking around and
[__] and [__] well I tell you this some
lady claimed she was virtually
um sexually harassed in the metaverse
she said her her Avatar was sexually
harassed by a group of men what and she
like filed a complaint and made this
thing on Instagram or she felt violated
and it's like you're Avatar
you're sitting at home alone with some
gobbles on you [__] Avatar is not a
[__] thing like some I don't even
care but I think you could Rob people
someone for living this [__] you would
you probably couldn't like put the mask
on and you know virtually Rob them yet
I'm sure that's coming but there's other
ways to rob people I'm just saying
crappy saying they'd be you know move
dealing with real money inside this [__]
Snoop Dogg owns a plot of land
that what I'm saying like [__] like that
like what the [__] like if people not
got done having like you know like
virtual reality chat type [__] yeah like
that what I'm saying and they got down
you know
yeah I mean listen
I haven't dived all the way in well you
need to dive in it [__] because
I want to know I'm afraid if I dive in I
ain't coming back nudie I want to make
sure before I dive ain't nobody gonna be
trying to take my [__] they're not gonna
take a [__] what do you have I mean they
might listen just don't get scammed
that's what it is you get scammed in
them like there was somebody who spent
like two million dollars to live next to
Snoop Dogg in the fake world
for like a piece of real estate next to
snoop's house yeah and I think I just
saw an article that it's worth like
seventy thousand dollars
that was so that was a robbery right you
know technically he got robbed and he's
like two million dollars poorer for it
he's staying there I don't know though
but where is he it's it's fake I don't
know none of this it doesn't matter it
literally right I think people are
starting to realize Snoop Dogg come in
now to them but he's not live there when
he talks amazing money grab from Snoop
though shout out to him yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah he he did it he did do
that
yes
um for you man uh
I know a lot of people are doing collab
tapes collab albums recently who would
you do a whole project with if you could
another artist that you haven't worked
with yet if I ever do a project
something I'm doing
I'm gonna do it with my cousin for
eign
yeah
plenty of time yeah you know would you
be boys and your family you know ain't
no [__] with [__] really be pressing
each other about no [__] right now you
guys just got a ton of unreleased music
together
yeah we're playing a little special back
in the day but [__] we got a whole bunch
of
gotta stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our family at Blue chew
baby that's right it's getting hot
outside you know what that means fellas
you're about to go get that dick wet you
know what I'm saying it might as well be
really hard it might as well be as hard
as it could possibly be and with
Bluetooth you will achieve such hardness
all right it's seriously amazing uh and
the best part about Bluetooth is you can
find out if it works don't just take my
word for it they're going to give you a
month's supply for free go to
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg get a month supply for free
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg now
it's the same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis minus the awkward
doctor appointment you do not have to go
see some old dude and tell them about
your erectile dysfunction issues in
person because that's a [__] awkward
conversation bruh all you got to do is
go to bluetooth.com right now use the
promo code bootleg they're going to get
you hooked up with a month of supply for
free you just got to pay five dollars in
shipping no awkward doctor's
appointments same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis plus they got the
Bluetooth mint it's a chewable it's
great tastes like mint it's also the
same active ingredient as Levitra so
summertime's coming fellas you don't
want to underperform make sure your dick
is rocked up baby all right go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
hey man it works what do you want from
me it [__] works everyone should have
a little Bluetooth in case of an
emergency
you might have an emergency you need to
pop a Bluetooth to it it's a chewable
you know what I mean anyway also got a
shout out to our family at Odd Socks
don't forget go to oddsoxofficial.com
promo code bootleg save 20 off man they
got the underwear that they just dropped
uh last year that's amazing so not only
do you get the most comfortable socks in
the world but you can also get the most
comfortable drawers in the world all the
crazy licenses they gotta have baked
socks they just announced their Hasbro
collection which is crazy because that
means you're going to get Monopoly socks
Transformer socks Power Ranger socks so
much [__] going with Odd Socks plus they
got The Odd Socks Basics my favorite
this is what I wear every day I wear the
basics because they're the most
comfortable socks I've ever put on my
[__] feet so experience the most
comfortable socks in the world with me
oddsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off shout out to Odd Socks let's
get back to the interview
do you keep those sessions if it's like
a 2016 session is it somewhere yeah like
you have just done them
do you have hard drives in a safe place
though hey yeah you got to get it safe
gotta keep them safe
you can't let this [__] happen again
was that um
disheartening to have your music leaked
and yeah it hurt me how many songs were
there it was like 200
[__] see what I'm saying can't let that
[__] happen again 200 songs because they
leak do you decide to not drop them at
all yeah I mean like [__] that [__] then
I already heard it so [__] I know
excitement for that [__] you know what
you got to do and all I'm saying they
lead the [__] oh them [__] won't
even know them that's probably gonna
piss you off even more like they should
they were old and that was just one
produce
um
[Music]
you should drop them as like you know
not you know Nas the rapper now so
obviously yeah he has the lost tape
Series so he'll put out like a bunch of
unreleased [__]
[__] one of his best albums ever is the
first Lost Tapes but it was like a
compilation of songs that never came out
or leaked no over like a 10-year period
or something like that he made good man
all that [__] it's a lot though I mean
bro you could put out a 200 song mixtape
but just Gucci so I think Gucci's last
album has like a a [__] 78 songs on
it
did you see that
yeah the new Gucci album has like I
think it's like 80 songs I can't listen
to no [__] with that many songs I can't
listen to 80 so I don't know the last
time I've listened to 80 songs like
in a month is that a lot that's what I'm
saying I don't see how the hell they're
gonna how the hell y'all gonna listen to
him or something yeah yeah you listen to
podcasts Puck yeah like or interviews or
like you know it depends
what do you like to listen to people
talk about anime nine depends on where
going on in the world
or with somebody saying or some [__] I
might want to go see they see what they
said in the podcast myself
so I can feel like how I pulled the feel
about the situation type [__] you
somebody like someone said something
about you no Disney Channel just in
general we'll be speaking about some
[__]
now you might see somebody to bash
somebody on Instagram they say oh he
said yeah I go see what he said yeah
cause you can't just trust the headline
yeah yeah no you can't never try no [__]
like that
probably got now I was speaking some
real [__] [__] you never uh said what
your favorite anime ever was man
yeah I thought we were gonna run around
that [__] that [__] up
my favorite anime set
I mean I feel like that was everybody
favorite anime dragon ball yeah like as
a kid
yeah Dragon Ball was the One Republic
yeah yeah as a kid yeah yeah but now my
favorite anime probably like
how'd you I fought with one punch man
that [__] oh what is the premise
my son watches that what's it about
there's no little is there a little I'm
trying to I'm trying to think
it's about getting punched once
let me Google it
one bunch
he basically like he like
I don't know because it's time for his
head on just straight just punch like
one punch out type [__] you know what
I'm saying but
like majority of all the people he
really get into it with
is it called one punch man yeah one
punch man
oh I see is like a ball dude yeah he
bald head
this fool looks like [__]
this fool looks like goddamn he ain't
got no superpowers either
so we just oh look at him well he him
like he's like a nerdy dude yeah yeah
so why so is he he
trying to say I don't know how the [__]
he's trying to sell to be be got down
that goddamn so he's a super so it's
about a superhero who's normal
yeah like you're a human basically yeah
you ever watch The Boondocks The
Boondocks yeah yeah
Boondocks is amazing Boondock gonna
always be that [__]
two seasons of The Boondocks are good
the last season was a little because the
main Rider quit yeah man I I like what's
your favorite character
I mean I love
I love Riley
right I mean Gramps is funny
I like what's the racist black dude who
hates yeah I know who I like wait no
Uncle Ruckus I said Clayton Bixby that's
Dave Chappelle's scary Uncle Ruckus yeah
Uncle Ricky that probably is the finest
[__] on that [__] bro that [__]
stupid as hell he said anything he don't
give a damn hold on bro Uncle Ruckus
I have so my best friend's brother works
on
you got to hear this drop
if I have it
this is the actual actor is this it hold
on hey America this is not
and even though he dressed and sound
like a donkey
oh Lord he smelled like Financial polish
and lemon zest God bless his white skin
laughs
hey yo shout out for the hill man bro I
mean he'll [__] [__] but he funny what
was like because the guy who voices a
few of the characters include Uncle
Ruckus yeah he did a drop he was doing
radio drops and [__] so I was like bro I
need Uncle Ruckus drop
yeah man that [__] funny hell man you
seen the one when he was a little kid
yes I've seen them all that [__] was so
goddamn funny boy yeah I like uh I like
the uh the the episode where the the
[__] lawyer dude
his wife gets snatched by Usher
do you remember the episodes Usher
snatches this dude's [__] and then he
goes and hires a pimp named slickback to
try to get his girl back
[__] hilarious by the way oh oh the
pimp
name yeah I know the little pimp with
the pink with the little the look yeah
yeah I know that cat we didn't care but
yeah yeah the parent will finally had to
they are so good man so good uh What is
something who who was rapping first you
were a Savage like when you guys were
did he because he obviously kind of got
a head start with you on the career-wise
but like did you guys kind of start
around the same time oh [__] I don't
know
it was close
I don't know he probably ran before me
forever yeah yeah I'd say it's true I
don't know
do you feel like seeing him like uh I
feel like he's done such a good job of
just like leveling up in terms of just
skill wise like
I just feel like every time I hear a new
Savage first I'm just like what the [__]
like no you guys got any sort of
friendly competition when you guys are
in the studio together
oh no no no I don't do that [__] like
that we really should go on that
[__] just do we probably do
either of you write stuff down or are
you doing off the head oh yeah this [__]
out here
so when you rap it's all off the head
do you do the melody then punch in no
what you mean like like how to be yeah
you might like
[Music]
no man I had my time when I punching I
had my time when I my my normal time
I'ma flow all the way through you know
what I'm saying oh just for real like
yeah I just go all the way through and
then clean it up then I go back down
through the guy now after I do that [__]
I just let the engineer go try to find a
hook or something between that [__] so
you'll lay down for the most part A one
take all the way through yeah yeah
off the top if I feel like I ain't
[__] up damn
that's right give me the right floor how
I want to make sure I don't [__] up
while I'm going
hey yeah that shit's crazy man it should
be that should be easy sometimes forever
are you like it does feel like the rap
[__] is easy for you do you uh challenge
yourself doing trying to like learn any
other new [__] like you're trying to
[__]
um
[__] they're laughing I just said they
were trying to um
I don't know how to write a rap and like
read it and wrap it you know what I'm
saying like I don't know how to do that
because you'll sound like you're reading
yeah it sounds like like I can't really
like make it it's not natural it ain't
natural and in my mind to be sitting up
I don't [__] that I can't so you like
you don't ever write an idea down at
least oh no I don't hell no you don't
have any ideas
you have to have ideas you're a very
smart man you have ideas
you got an idea to put a snake on a
[__] dinner table for the album cover
that's a [__] idea I go out the beat
I have the beat sound the beat the beat
tell me what I need to do you ever
thought of a line like one line to be
like oh I gotta use that
um no
damn
it's very very very
um
prolific of you as a writer or as a
non-writer even oh I just go in the
studio in Nigeria I don't know black out
yeah basically I turned into a rep I
mean you are a rapper yeah yeah yeah it
is what it is and that [__]
would you act
what I am like in a movie like Jack
Harlow just dropped a movie would you
act oh and then I already were you
acting in oh I act like a rapper
I see what you did there yeah and also
apparently a part-time comedian
oh [__]
oh man shout out to you
yeah
shoot me off a little bit yeah
just a little bit man
um all right so the album Gumbo's out
obviously you got uh your cousin on
there you've got
key locks on there right yeah shout out
to key Glock um
when you hang out with people from
Memphis and they say music
do you be like
it's music
I ain't really just kidding around on
people from Memphis I gotta ask
I have all the Memphis guys come up and
they say music yeah it's like their
thing uh no I ain't really just had No
Light No like if you and key Glock
weren't in the studio together did you
just send it over and you send it back
yeah [__] inside [__] but now I'm kicked
in studio Shadow before I ain't no [__]
like that I [__] with y'all what is the
difference between like uh
working with
because
shatu you worked with Lil yachty
obviously yachty's a [__] great
writer he wrote backed up by the city
girls
there's someone like him write [__] down
as opposed to like someone like your
cousin who's just going in and you know
how long what the hell because I'm
seeing Lil yachty's like a very good
writer he's written for other artists so
when you record with Lil yachty is he
writing
oh [__] I ain't never been in studio
shot I think well
only one time when he did no clue that
was the only time yeah I went I was in
another room what's your funnest studio
session you've ever been in
and what's going on
oh no
my funny studio session will probably
I don't know when my funny studio
session was
what do you like about business at the
studio are you let the homies kick it
yeah I let Rogue I'm kidding and [__] on
downstairs
are you the kind of like guy who comes
pretty deep to the stew no hell no
because you know there's some guys like
I own the studios and like I had my day
where I might be like hey
you know everybody can kick and I ain't
really tripping then I had my day where
I don't like being bothered right yeah
it'd be like that sometimes you how you
know you always hear and we live in LA
and people always hear about how late is
crazy but we always hear people getting
[__] like La Atlanta New York the
crime is crazy right now in terms of
people getting robbed and [__]
you feel like it's gotten like a lot
worse out there for you not even just
for you but just like for everybody like
because I feel like that energy has
gotten worse since the pandemic started
um
you know I don't really be worrying
about that type of [__] right yeah make
sure you move correctly that's all I can
tell you you're real for real do you go
to like uh ever go to the Hawks games I
was just saying that the Trey young
might get traded to the Lakers they were
saying no hell no they be trying to get
me to go well you won't go no I ain't
got into all the sports [__] like that
yet man you gotta go boozy's Courtside
every game yeah I'd be saying Boosie
acting a fool
shouting crazy man this is crazy bro
yeah uh so go get the album June 29th
the show was in LA at the novo you got
anybody opening
um I got a baby drill
and I got that boy two feet man yeah
shout out to that boy two feet man can't
forget about my boy shouting hard too
special guest probably
um
people don't [__] with me I don't think
that's true man I don't [__] I don't
know
you're dumb I mean you know it's cool
it's a it's a what's up nude I [__] I
wish I like your music and it's oh yeah
new to my boy I [__] with him yeah hit
me up type [__] who is um your best best
friend outside of Atlanta in the hip-hop
space like which artist would you say is
like a real friend that you've made that
isn't from like your hometown since you
know becoming young nudie
um
on the music too
I don't know for real foreign Hollywood
offset yeah I caught my Hollywood oh he
knows that [__] he's great yeah that my
brother I fought with him but outside of
that [__] I don't really you know you
know me and my cousin you know we locked
in so I don't really I can't really
count him in no [__] like that of course
not other than that I ain't really got
no rapper when you really be like like
what's up type [__] what's happening no
homies yeah
I ain't really trying to be with that
[__] and that [__] come with too much of
too much you know I was gonna say it
feels like somehow you're still after
all like I feel like you've put out
multi like album of the Year contenders
over your career like somehow you're
still underrated maybe you don't get the
the accolades that I feel like you
deserve do you do you feel that way and
why why do you think it is that way you
think it's because you're anti-social or
oh no [__]
oh [__] they should be sleeping on [__]
sometime for real for real but you know
it gets to the point where it'd be like
[__] I don't really be giving a [__]
because like [__] I got my own fans and
[__] you feel that my [__] getting
bigger you ain't getting smaller I mean
like that boy [__] did some [__]
that everybody like it ain't like all
these some nudity fans you feel what I'm
saying there's some [__] that everybody
like I ain't wishing I ain't tripping
about that I love that you know what I'm
saying but other than that like [__] you
know
I've been in my own little world with my
[__] so bro I don't know do you feel
like you're like
okay
your fans are they mosh pitting is there
a mosh happening are you getting the
[__] if you have mosh Pitbull music
I got it boo I got more like I might
have a crunk like they just lit the
dusty footed white chicks with Air
Forces and a mosh pit it's like
[Music]
why are you doing like that you know
they're at your shows
I love all my friends
there's a lot of dirty forces clean
forces I got all type of [__] coming in
now I'm seeing the mosh pits [__]
like you got like the fans are are they
I have my spirits and then hell no I
ain't happening now um hell nah them
folks in there swinging and throwing
bows and [__] man I'm gonna tell I'm
gonna flip out we're gonna show gonna be
over with corn we gonna be out that big
hand have you ever uh
crap crowd surfed crap sir no yeah no I
ain't trying to jump out there man I
ain't no little [__] you feel me
touche yeah
yeah me either yeah that is true you
might get dropped I've been dropped yeah
you know I really be shocking a lot of
people when they see me in person
by your size yeah you know majority of
people think rappers and got them [__]
like you know short small like average
height type [__] I you know and then see
me further and say damn I ain't know you
that tall I thought you was a little
shorty like six foot like I see it when
I see it too she's two you're a point
guard in the NBA I ain't playing no
basketball I'm saying that's six two
it's point guard you'll be a point guard
hmm could be Gary Payton
um never played Sports
well when I was a kid like football like
high school sports nah I'll I'll plan on
some other [__] because I
yeah yeah airplane yeah there it is well
look man the album is out go run it up
uh June 29th the tickets to the show
uh anything else going on
oh [__]
I don't know man I'm just I'm just
chilling forever
I don't know doing a lot of press
yeah [__] basically like forever
[Music]
well go get the album gumbo
gumbo I know all that [__] appreciate
you pulling up man hey man I appreciate
you for having me man you feel me yes
sir yes sir there it is why you smoke
that why don't you smoke that up yeah
because it's [__] it died out and I
don't want to I don't know I also you
just said right here fake smoker this is
not fake this was long oh no this should
we on camera bruh
[__] smoke both of these
you smell both now yes did they
just right now in front of you
you did not catch me smoking the whole
[__] interview I seen you smoking
that loud two of them I remember you
smoking the furrow I probably wasn't
paying attention I probably was all
about
zoned out because you've had eight of
them
by the way I ain't been smoking no weed
for show that was a tobacco cigarette
y'all then was tobacco cigarettes
hey we gotta wrap up an interview
brought to you by hardean Las Vegas
appreciate y'all watching hey don't
forget when you go to Vegas you got to
go to Hardee man it's the craziest
dispensary you'll ever walk into it
smells like [__] heaven in there all
right get in that Uber when you hit Sin
City tell him take me to Jardine they're
gonna take you you're gonna get a wild
selection of the just top top of the
line cannabis the best selection you'll
go uh be able to see in the U.S Plus on
top of that they got the crazy gear they
got the clothes they got the bikinis
they got a wonderful selection of Bud
tenders that are very good at their job
man they'll take care of you tell them
that bootleg have sent you the bud
tenders are Jardine don't know what that
means they're gonna get you hooked up
right all right go follow them online
Harding underscore Las Vegas or just go
check out their website too man
hardinglasvegas.com and when you're in
Vegas pull up to Jardin or you're
playing yourself for real